in den letzten monaten hatte ich die
möglichkeit unheimlich viele luxuriöse
dinge zu testen egal ob hotels für über
700 euro zugreisen durch die schweiz für
über 500 euro oder einen flug der sage
und schreibe 1800 euro gekostet hätte
gibt es aber eine möglichkeit günstiger
an diesen luxus zu kommen und wenn ja
was er zu bieten und warum hat man
abstriche um das herauszufinden habe ich
dem vielleicht günstigsten langstrecken
wildes class flug gebucht und für euch
getestet wie viel wir bezahlt haben und
was man dort alles für sein geld
bekommen hat erfahrt ihr in diesem video
aber warte mal wie ist es eigentlich
dazu gekommen bin gerade eigentlich für
ein völlig anderes video am flughafen
und fliegen nach new york gerade kam
aber zufällig diese durch sein
die business class ist so leer dass sie
wirklich probieren die plätze einfach
noch weg zu bekommen und das ist
eigentlich meine chance an den
günstigsten business class flug der welt
zu kommen deswegen gehen wir sofort hin
fragen wie viel das kostet und
das upgrade
329 euro gekostet der conunit platz hat
119 euro gekauft das bedeutet unter 450
euro für einen business platz und ich
bin ehrlich gespannt was der kampf und
ich sage ganz im ernst der letzte
business class flug bei 1800 euro hätte
der eigentlich gekostet das lohnt sich
in keiner welt jetzt fliege ich aber nur
zwei stunden länger befinden acht
stunden lang nach new york über den tag
hinweg und natürlich ist man komplett
jetlag wenn man ankommt wenn ich das
jetzt für 450 euro inklusive luxus
inklusive schlafen inklusive allem
umgehen kann dann ist das ein preis bei
dem es sich lohnen kann wenn man quasi
wirklich arbeitsmäßig unterwegs bin was
ich bin ich bin richtig gespannt
natürlich können wir das flugzeug als
erstes worden und jetzt bin ich wirklich
gespannt was mich erwartet jetzt eine
767 300 kein besonders neues flugzeug
aber vielleicht hat dieses klassikers zu
bieten die fluggesellschaft mit der
befliegen ist condor natürlich hat die
jetzt keine super neue flotte wie eine
lufthansa mit einer a350 die langstrecke
fliegt oder so aber eine 767 300 tut es
auch ein solides gutes flugzeug
und das war also mein sitz der erste
eindruck ziemlich gut aber natürlich
jetzt nicht so wie es damals bei
emirates war zwischen den sitzen liegt
aber auch ein preisunterschied von 1400
euro also mal sehen was der kampf
[Musik]
wichtig ist jetzt schön entspannt
zurücklehnen und die zeit bei uns an
bord gewesen und erst mal alles gute für
ihr könnt es gerade schon sehen wie im
ersten flug haben wir auch ein warmes
erfrischungstuch bekommen als er
reingekommen sind aber nicht nur das
sondern natürlich auch den gewohnten
schaumwein der schaumwein war jetzt
vielleicht kein champagner wie bei
emirates aber das sollte sich im laufe
des fluges ja vielleicht noch ändern und
bevor wir jetzt auf den sitz den komfort
die einstellungsmöglichkeiten und
allgemeinem einen ersten eindruck gehen
erst mal das essen
[Musik]
unser frühstück sieht sehr gut aus wir
haben fischer am irgendwie anders sieht
super angerichtet aus wirklich ziemlich
gut zwischen st
ich bin ich gespannt ob es auch so gut
schmeckt wie es aussieht und wie es im
vergleich zu 1800 euro business class
sitz abschneidet in dem ich bei einem
hammer zu tun aber jetzt wird erst mal
gegessen
[Musik]
ich habe keine ahnung warum aber direkt
nach dem frühstück oder gefühlten
frühstück kam jetzt der hauptgang wir
haben rinder fleisch knödeln und rotkohl
ich bin super gespannt weil das auch
wieder super nach dem letzten run ist
hätte auch noch die möglichkeit gehabt
mich für heilbutt mit homer soße und
tomatenrot zu entscheiden ich wusste
aber nicht mal was es ist die vorspeise
war super jetzt bin ich gespannt was und
wie hier rechts oben seht hatte ich auch
endlich die möglichkeit einen champagner
zu bestellen aber nicht nur das es gab
eine riesige weinkarte und noch eine
menge andere getränk
das ist jetzt gar nummer 5 und ich bin
froh dass es zu ende geht nicht weil es
nicht gut schmeckt sondern weil ich
langsam wirklich klappen sagt bin aber
wie würde ich das essen bewerben an sich
war das frühstück top es hat super
geschmeckt aber ich habe nicht so
richtig verstanden warum die sachen
sofort nacheinander kam weiter mit der
rinderroulade die hat etwas trocken
geschmeckt und war allgemein jetzt
einfach nicht so mega hoch wird trotz
alledem immer noch deutlich besser als
alles was ich jemals in der economy
class gegessen der nachtisch naja es war
ein fertiger machen und das andere was
das überhaupt es hat auf jeden fall
nicht so zehn von zehn gesperrt im
vergleich zum emirates flug musste man
aber schon einige abstriche machen im
emirates flug hatte man beispielsweise
das gefühl dass das obst frisch vom feld
kam das war hier jetzt nicht unbedingt
der fall aber nichtsdestotrotz war das
essen qualitativ hochwertig und ganz
einfach zu sagen im kontor business
class flug hatte man schon das gefühl
naja flugzeugessen zu bekommen das
gefühl hatte man im emirates flug nicht
was ziemlich leise ist und womit ich
nicht gerechnet hätte ist dass das bad
komplett zu einer fläche zu machen also
ich dachte okay sind wissens glas aber
das wird hier nicht funktionieren die
wird nicht genug platz dafür ein als ich
das erste mal einen platz bekommen wird
aber
[Musik]
das wahrscheinlich die eine funktion die
mir in der business class wirklich geld
und ist bei man kann den jetlag das
überspringt in dem man vernünftig
schläft und das funktioniert nur mit
einer graben lang vielleicht wirklich
auf einem der besten sachen vom ersten
und auch jetzt vom zweiten business
class punkt ist dass niemand direkt
neben mir sitzt und nicht nur das
sondern die plätze daneben sind auch
noch also ich habe quasi komplett privat
gehen die nächste person sitzt und
letzter weg um die idee dahinter meese
durch diese wand von mir abgetrennt ich
nachdem ich mich nicht
bestens und ich habe viel mehr
privatsphäre als natürlich einem
normalen economy setzen
ich kann mich hier raus 3 mich hinlegen
und niemand bekommt davon mit können
diese kamera reden
nun ja und ich hatte glück dass niemand
im flugzeug war denn ich konnte meinen
bereich nicht so gut ab trendy bei
emirates hatte man eine band die man
selber hoch und runter fahren konnte
sodass man entscheiden kann ob man mit
seinem sitznachbarn kommunizieren möchte
oder nicht man hat einen eigenen bereich
wieder so eine eigene höhle die man sich
einrichten konnte auf seinem flug das
war bei condor einfach nicht davon ist
jetzt nicht so tragisch gewesen weil das
flugzeug in meinem fall komplett leer
war aber in einem vollen flugzeug ist
das schon wichtig und macht super viel
aus das sind aber natürlich alles
luxusprobleme sein hauptzweck hat der
sitz erfüllt ich konnte schlafen und ich
habe natürlich auch ein kissen und eine
decke bekommen auch wenn die nicht so
richtig mit denen von amri zu
vergleichbaren am entertainment gab es
wirklich nichts auszusetzen klar ich
habe keinen psp artiges bediensystem
dazugekommen wie beim raid aber an und
für sich war alles vorhanden was wir
gebraucht haben gute filme vernünftige
fluginformationen ich konnte die
stewardess über das entertainment-system
bestellen und noch vieles mehr was nicht
vorhanden war waren games was mir jetzt
aber auch nicht besonders fehlt weil
meistens bringen die auf so einem
flugzeug entertainmentsystem eh nichts
ok insgesamt habe ich 448 euro für
diesen flug bezahlt aber lohnt sich das
in welcher welt lohnt sich das für wen
lohnt sich das und allgemein wie war die
experience mit knapp 1400 euro günstiger
als der emirates flug ist es auf jeden
fall etwas das man sich mal gönnen kann
um die experience mit zu haben nicht so
wie bei dem emirates flug bei dem ich
sagen wir das lohnt sich für niemanden
außer für leute bei denen das die firma
bezahlt bei diesem flug wenn man sich
das mal gönnen will dann ist das ein
absoluter traum die erfahrung ist es
wert und ich würde es euch tatsächlich
empfehlen natürlich muss man schauen ob
man darauf lust hat und man sich für den
luxus begeistern kann ich kann das und
ich kann zwegat außerdem kann ich euch
sagen ich konnte den jetlag wirklich
kippen also ich habe wirklich ein
bisschen schlaf bekommen und konnte dann
quasi in der amerikanischen zeit einfach
so weitermachen wenn da angekommen und
konnte sofort arbeiten nach den ganzen
tag durchgehalten und hab mir dadurch
quasi ban tag in new york aus katern
oder also nicht aus karte einmal
ausschlafen erspart was mir mehr als 400
48 euro wert gewesen wären ich meine
wenn ihr das nicht habt und ein tag im
bett rum liegt und einen tag urlaub
verpasst dann ist das vielleicht sogar
ein bisschen mehr geld wert wenn man es
schon mal auf den anderen kontinent
schafft essen war okay nicht
vergleichbar mit dem emirates flug aber
war an sich super champagner hat
geschwenkt das bett war gut
entertainment war gut und ich bin super
entspannt angekommen also es hat sich
allemal gelohnt man muss selber wissen
ob man darauf lust hat ich hoffe euch
hat das video gefallen wenn ja dass wir
gerne leica vergesst nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren und dann sehen wir uns am
sonntag wieder
[Musik]